JEAN JEAN WELCOME BACK TO
ASSEMBLY IS SCHEDULED TO
VOTE ON A RESOLUTION
OPPOSING ANY RESOLUTION OF
JERUSALEM AS ISRAEL'S
CAPITAL.
THIS COMES AS PRESIDENT
TRUMP EARLIER THIS MONTH
BOLDLY ANNOUNCED HIS
INTENTIONS TO MOVE OUR
EMBASSY FROM TEL AVIV TO
JERUSALEM.
U.N. AMBASSADOR NIKKI HALEY
IS WARNING THAT THE U.S.
WILL BE TAKING NAMES.
AND TODAY DURING A CABINET
MEETING, PRESIDENT TRUMP
DOUBLED DOWN ON AMBASSADOR
HALEY'S MESSAGE, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> I LIKE TO MESSAGE THAT
NIKKI SENT YESTERDAY AT THE
UNITED NATIONS FOR ALL OF
THESE NATIONS THAT TAKE OUR
MONEY AND THEN THEY VOTE
AGAINST US AT THE SECURITY
COUNCIL.
OR THEY VOTE AGAINST US
POTENTIALLY AT THE ASSEMBLY.
THEY TAKE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND EVEN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND THEN
THEY VOTE AGAINST US.
LET THEM VOTE AGAINST US.
WE WILL SAVE A LOT.
WE DON'T CARE.
THEM HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND NOBODY KNOW WHAT
IS THEY ARE DOING.
NIKKI, THAT WAS THE
YESTERDAY.
I HAVE HAD A LOT OF GOOD
COMMENT.
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF THE
UNITED STATES, PEOPLE LIVE
HERE GREAT CITIZENS THEY ARE
TIRED OF THIS COUNTRY BEING
ADVANTAGE OF ANY LONGER.
>> Judge Jeanine: JOINING US
WITH AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED NATIONS DANNY DALON.
DANNY, I LOVE THE IDEA OF
TAKING NAMES.
I LOVE THE IDEA OF YOU ARE
NOT GOING TO DO THIS TO US
ANYMORE IS IT ANYBODY'S
BUSINESS WHERE WE PUT
ISRAEL.
>> THE U.N. HAS NO RIGHT TO
TELL THE U.S. WHERE TO PUT
I THINK TOMORROW WE WILL SEE
ANOTHER SESSION OF BASHING
NOT ONLY OF ISRAEL, BASHING
OF THE U.S. AND NO
RESOLUTION THAT IS PASSED
CAN CHANGE THE REALITY THAT
JERUSALEM IS AND ALWAYS WILL
BE THE CAPITAL OF THE STATE
OF ISRAEL.
YOU CANNOT CHANGE THAT.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THIS
PRESIDENT OBVIOUSLY HE IS
WERE THEY AFRAID OF THESE
OTHER COUNTRIES?
>> WE SEE A DIFFERENT KIND
OF LEADERSHIP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SECURITY COUNCIL.
I WAS AT THE SECURITY
COUNCIL LAST SEPTEMBER AND
THERE WAS ANOTHER
RESOLUTION.
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORTED THAT SHAMEFUL
RESOLUTION.
WE SEE THE CHANGE, WE
APPRECIATE IT THIS IS A WAY
TO U.N. TO COME WITH YOUR
VALUES AND IDEOLOGY AND TO
CHANGE THE U.N.
WE NEED TO REFORM THE U.N.
>> Judge Jeanine: CLEARLY
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO DO
THAT.
HE TALKED ABOUT IT WITH NATO
AND NOW HE IS TALKING ABOUT
IT WITH THE U.N.
WHAT MONEY, I MEAN, IS THERE
MONEY TO INDIVIDUAL
COUNTRIES THAT CAN BE
IMPACTED BY, YOU KNOW, THE
UNITED STATES SAYING YOU
DON'T VOTE WITH US, WE ARE
NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU MONEY
ANYMORE?
>> THAT'S FOR THE PRESIDENT
U.N.
IF YOU GIVE MONEY TO THOSE
COUNTRIES, THEY THINK YOU
HAD SHOULD DEMAND FROM THEM.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO WHEN WE
SUPPORT COUNTRIES.
I CALLED MANY AMBASSADORS
TODAY.
WE SAID WE SUPPORT YOU.
TECHNOLOGY, CYBER SECURITY,
DEFENSE, NOW WE NEED YOU TO
WILL ALSO TAKE NOTES.
>> Judge Jeanine: EVEN THE
UNITED KINGDOM.
THEY ARE ALWAYS SUPPOSED TO
BE CONSIDERED AN ALLY.
WHY DO THEY FEEL THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE A SAY AS TO
WHERE ISRAEL HAS ITS CAPITAL
>> THEY SEE THE PEACE
PROCESS EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE.
THEY DON'T SUPPORT THE PEACE
PROCESS.
THEY SUPPORT THE PALESTINIAN
IDEOLOGY OF INCITEMENT OF
THE ONLY WAY TO MOVE FORWARD
IS DIRECT NEGOTIATION
BETWEEN ISRAELIS AND
PALESTINIANS.
THE PRESIDENT'S DECISION IS
THE RIGHT MOVE BECAUSE NOW
THAT UNDERSTANDS NEW
LEADERSHIP.
NEGOTIATIONS OR MOVING ON
YOU KNOW, THIS IS GOING TO
DISRUPT THE PEACE PROCESS IT
HASN'T GONE FORWARD FOR A
I THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH.